a lot of Americans are no longer tipping
uh 20 percent it's adjusting and that's
another sign by the way I want to go
through this fairly quickly uh are
Americans reaching a Tipping Point when
it comes down to well tipping that could
be the big takeaway from the recent
survey that signal a possible shift in
attitudes about gratitudes uh uh one
survey from uh Pompano a restaurant tech
company found a decline in the
percentage of consumers who say they tip
20 or more restaurants from 56 in 2021
to 43 this year that's a decline of 13
another survey from play USA a website
that covers online gambling found that
60 of Americans said they would like to
do away with tipping all together and go
European style what's behind the
sentiment
inflation appears to be playing a role
the U.S the play USA survey based on
response of a thousand six people noted
that 17 of Americans said they were
tipping less due to Rising costs do you
remember a year and a half ago they were
talking about how people are tipping
more they're doing 25 something percent
now it's going backwards again this is
another sign well people are sitting
there saying okay instead of tipping you
19 I'm gonna only tip you sixteen
dollars three dollars may not seem like
a lot of money but they're actually
thinking about it yeah I mean well it
kind of goes to the story about in 2020
more people were paying off debt now
there are more people are accumulating
debt I'll tell you a crazy story so uh I
eat this sushi restaurant in South Beach
we've eaten there moshi moshi I've named
my freaking cats Moshi and miso after
this freaking restaurant it's my
favorite restaurant love it it's open
till 5 a.m so like oh wow you leave a
club go get some sushi so I go I get the
I go to sit down I'm with a lady friend
of mine we have a bite and uh the waiter
comes up gives up some Waters I was like
all right can we put in some appetizers
she goes yeah yeah it's on the you gotta
just do it on the app now I said well
you're right here I'll just can I get
some miso soups yeah no you got to do it
on the app I'm like I gotta download the
app you're here I'm talking to you it's
like the scene in the 40 year old
version when he's like came into the
store he's like I'd like to buy these
shoes she's like you gotta buy it on
eBay he's like I'm here in front of you
I would just like to buy them off of you
I had the most awkward exchange with
this guy I'm like I would like to order
sushi sorry do it on the app I'm like
I'm talking to you in your face bro so
we go to this whole song and dance I do
the whole app thing and then at the end
of the day he goes yeah you know I put
my card in there and I pay and I go all
right uh there's no option to give you a
tip he's like yeah we don't we don't do
tips anymore don't do tips anymore what
so the restaurant that I've eaten at
more than probably any restaurant Miami
no longer has a server that serves you
you have to do it on the app okay and
now when all is said and done the
restaurant has shut down tipping they
also cancel ginger dressing which I
almost freaked out for that so is the
price of the sushi going up the price I
don't know if it did or I might have
because inflation but things are
changing like you're recognizing these
things that are happening very
interesting so but this is a restaurant
that I've eaten at a hundred plus times
and all of a sudden they deviate it I'll
tell you one more thing the most awkward
thing ever right now is going and paying
doing your Apple pay tap they flip the
screen around it says here would you
like to do a tip yeah and it gives you
10 15 20 25 it's like I just spot a
Starbucks bro like I'm like I'm not
tipping you [ __ ] okay and they're like
oh really okay
oh really zero zero his tipping culture
is getting very weird out there these
days that's just as awkward like you go
to CVS and then you're finished and they
go do you want to give a dollar to a
starving kid
and this is my first experience with
this I went to Australia this is uh you
know 20 2009 2010
there's no tipping whatsoever but they
pay the employees this was the I don't
know the double minimum wage so they're
paying employees 25 bucks an hour where
they pay you you know 12 bucks an hour
or whatever the number is and but
there's no tipping but when there's no
tipping that means don't expect great
service of course right like there's the
ying and the Yang the risk and the
reward so if there's no accountability
in the service of the restaurant why
would you need to tip so yeah things go
down I like tipping you know what tip
stands for
tip is an Ackerman stands for to ensure
prompt service
wow oh wow that's great it's become a
posture
actions early days it was to ensure
prompt service well you gave a couple
dollars to get a table and insure prompt
service I appreciated that you
pre-appreciated order your future looks
bright hat click over here into watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]